okay welcome to the live stream thanks
for joining me I actually don't have
that much of an agenda for this live
stream there has just been so much
craziness in the last 24 hours after
these videos of cultural critic and
internet sensation Dave Rubin went viral
of him being asked by people at one
university in California at the
University of Delaware
will he interview or debate me or Sam
cedar or whoever else and all sorts of
stuff have exploded has exploded there
is an interesting post on the I believe
it's is it on the Reuben or the Sam
Harris subreddit which I'll pull up on
the Dave Rubin subreddit which we'll
take a look at I'll kind of update you
on what's been going on but it has
begotten very very crazy and I don't
really know what the end game is with
any of this stuff last night I was sort
of texting with a bunch of the usual
suspects in the progressive YouTube
sphere I don't know what to call it and
everybody just kind of wondering you
know should what like what is the goal
of all of this stuff are we trying to
actually sit down and have a
conversation with Dave Rubin or are we
tree like what what is it what are we
trying to do and you know my priority
has always been I have ideas that are
mostly progressive but are informed by
the facts over my feelings too to cite
and often an overused a catchphrase or
talking point at this point in time and
I'm not paying particularly close
attention to the specifics of what my
audience wants me to say in other words
I was just talking actually with a
prominent public intellectual who many
many of you I'm sure know and we were
talking about this idea of becoming
beholden to your audience in a way that
you start to put out content that is
primarily informed by what your audience
wants rather than primarily informed by
what it is that you believe to be true
and presenting sort of like your genuine
self and over the years I've had call
them battles I've had disagreements with
what I guess I would call like my core
audience which would
leftists but not socialists and
communists etc right I mean I think like
the core of my audience is certainly to
the left of Hillary Clinton and Joe
Biden but they are to the right of where
communism and Stalinism would typically
be placed on the political spectrum
although I think there's a very good
case to be made as I've made that
Stalinism in in practice is
extraordinarily authoritarian that
doesn't mean it's right-wing but it is
authoritarian which is a characteristic
of sort of reactionary politics and I do
the show that is my genuine views and
that's really all that I promise to do
and usually there's kind of like a good
match between me and my audience on that
on that basis and sometimes there's a
disconnect sometimes I will say
something about you know the
israeli-palestinian conflict or
Venezuela or Russia or Syria or whatever
and there will notably be a bigger piece
of my core audience or what I perceive
to be my core audience that disagrees
with me and when I think about what is
it that's going on with Dave Rubin like
what what you know we used to be in
regular contact and we aren't anymore
what what explains this and some say
well he's just paid now he's paid and so
he'll say whatever the people who pay
him want to want him to say and I think
that that's a overly simplistic point of
view if I had to sort of give my best
assessment of what's going on with Dave
Rubin I think he was always a
center-left guy and at a certain point
in time there came this sort of
opportunity to do something that is more
initially center-right libertarian and
it always felt sort of genuine right it
maybe wasn't a hundred percent genuine
but it was like 90 percent genuine and
then over time opportunities came
together and money came together and all
of this stuff we're at no point did it
become Rubin is straight up saying
things that he doesn't believe at all I
think it's a sort of there's a degree of
audience capture and there's a degree of
notoriety that is available to Dave
Rubin and
has led to taking some positions that
are now a departure from the positions
he would consider the most important
ones in terms of defining his political
identity eight years ago and it's sort
of a combination of things it's a
combination of all of these things that
have led to this persona and it has put
him in direct conflict with some of the
people that I think he formerly was very
much on board with politically me being
one example am i being overly careful
with what I say no I'm not I just want
to be you know I think there's a
possibility that Dave Rubin and I could
come together in some format it could be
in an in person you know live event it
could be on his show or my show I don't
know if he's interested in that but I'd
be glad to host something like that and
we could actually sort out a lot of this
stuff in a civil way and if there's one
thing I'm able to do and it's not it's
not necessarily an accomplishment it's
just sort of my disposition
personality-wise I'm able to have civil
conversations with people who disagree
with me politically I'm able to have
civil conversations with people who hold
disgusting views and I think that I
would be able to actually break down a
lot of this stuff with Dave Rubin if we
were to sit down and say let's talk
about your political awakening in detail
let's talk about you know the lies you
claim I told about you let's hash all of
this stuff out and sort of see see where
we end I don't know you know I can't
speak for anybody else Sam cedar has a
very different on-air persona than I do
Kyle kolinsky has a very different
on-air persona than I do Natalie win
another person who's been brought up as
would you talk to Natalie win every one
of these folks is different and it's not
for me to say whether they would all be
civil discussions or not or whether they
would all be productive what I can say
is I would have no problem putting aside
sort of the the the sniping and the
partisan stuff that has happened with
Rubin over the last six to twelve months
and just having a conversation about as
he likes to do ideas and the ideas that
he has and the ideas that I have and and
we could sort of go from there now as
far as the reaction to yesterday's
segment so let me put this up on the
screen
here so yesterday I did a segment called
dave rubin calls me a liar when
confronted about dodging me and in this
segment there was one point at which one
individual asked dave rubin a question
about would he debate me or have me on
and dave rubin during this sort of
responded we can even get to his
response actually let's just listen to
exactly what he had to say so we're all
working with the same in this point in
time i wasn't sure if he was referring
to me when he was talking about you know
lying about me personally and and all of
this different stuff but then there was
another clip from an appearance at the
University of Delaware where he actually
does say pac-man has lied about me
multiple times and this is where it
starts to get a little bit you know
problematic cuz I don't know what he's
talking about let's take a listen to
that at the University of Delaware again
he's asked about me and such claims
pac-man has lied about me multiple times
take a listen to this the audio is not
great but you can hear it alright can I
do I am 11 alright easy questions is
there anyone I know you want to beat Sam
cedar the majority report is there
anyone on the progressives David Pakman
or from counter points that you would be
willing to have a discussion
I know he you had him on the show once
okay Pacman's lied about me a bunch of
times
I want to hash out what those lives were
I just I just want to know what the lies
were and the reaction from people has
been on Twitter it has been crazy and by
the way I have no problem with people
politely saying to him hey Dave you know
you claim David Pakman lied he's
expressed interest in hashing out what
those lives are let's do it and I've
been retweeting those because I think it
would be an interesting conversation and
quite frankly let's not let's not lie if
Dave Rubin and I actually had a
conversation about what have I said what
haven't I said what lies have I told as
far as he's concerned that would do well
for him and it would do well for me I
think that he has the the idea that it's
either beneath him or that maybe it
wouldn't be be a productive conversation
and I just completely disagree if you
want to tweet to him and say hey let's
have this conversation with David Pakman
David's going to be in Los Angeles soon
which hopefully I'll be able to tell you
about in the next week or two some very
exciting stuff going on in Los Angeles
California that I will be participating
in hopefully in the next month or two
let's set it up I think that that would
be a great thing to do and the reaction
has been all over the map I want to show
you one thread from the Dave this is the
Dave Rubin subreddit which has actually
become very anti Dave Rubin and this is
just a post from from that video I told
you and the interview that I referenced
at the end of yesterday's clip is a
subject of much discussion so for
example this first user said I believe
that at the end of this video Pakman
hinted at the real reason he suspects
Rubin won't have him on his show it was
so embarrassing when Pakman interviewed
him that he would never subject himself
to that again Rubin obviously resents
Pakman for that interview which wasn't
even that tough Reubens just such flimsy
pundit that the slightest pushback or
follow-up causes him to implode I know
the Pakman interview bothers Rubin
because he blocked me when I brought it
up on Twitter we're gonna republish that
next week next week I'm actually going
to be away and we're putting together a
bunch of different content in addition
to our guest host and one of the things
we're going to do is republish that
Rubin interview so that everybody can
take a look at it and sort of judge it
for themselves
I think it
and McGann it was an extraordinarily
fair interview the interview was too
fair if anything I handled Dave with not
kid gloves but with a light touch sort
of out of respect for what at the time
was our personal relationship and I
think you will find that it was
exceedingly fair and and and maybe too
much and as you read through this
discussion and I know people are saying
this has become an anti Reuben subreddit
it seems that a lot of the issue here is
the double standard of claiming to be
about civil discussion we're divergent
ideas are discussed and yet there's a
lot of people who are actually
advocating for progressive policy I mean
I don't have a problem with the
left-wing guests that dave has on who
are overwhelmingly talking about the
problems of the left like that's fine I
talk about the problems of the left as
well but when you don't just bring
people on not because they're you know
celebrity leftist that you think are
gonna get you clicks and likes but
because they're actually coherently and
intelligently advocating right
opposition to right-wing policy
left-wing policy ideas I think that
that's where it sort of becomes
problematic and the biggest thing I'm
seeing in this thread is just have the
battle of ideas if you're really going
to have it it has to be a diverse battle
of ideas where we actually give a proper
audience to the true diversity of ideas
that's out there so that's my general
view now and I'm willing to appear you
know any place with Dave and hash this
out or with whoever else I mean people
have said David what about ben shapiro
you interviewed ben shapiro in the past
again i think it's possible ben shapiro
has become too big for the david pakman
show but i would appear with him i'd be
glad to have him appear with me and
let's actually have some of these you
know it doesn't have to be this gotcha
stuff i get everybody now is claiming at
least to go against the GOC of stuff
that's fine let's let's have these
conversations so let me welcome people
once again if this is your first David
Pakman show live stream I will remind
you these are live these are actually
live unless it's a replay you can use
super chat to ask questions and to send
comments they will pop up on the screen
and I will
read those and I will respond to them if
there are questions I will answer the
questions if there are comments I will
read and react to them also the number
one funding source for the David Pakman
show is individual memberships and you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership the normal
rates are really cheap and I think an
incredibly good deal I understand not
everybody can afford 6 bucks a month or
60 for the year so if you want to take a
discount take a discount we're not
checking taxes
fortunately for people like Trump and
others we are not looking at tax returns
if you want to save 40 percent use the
coupon code this is 20 20 that'll save
you 40 percent if you want to get like
an extra special deal use the coupon
code save 35 on the $60 a year
membership and you'll get a year
membership for 25 bucks we do a daily
extra show just for members if you're
not a member you don't even know about
this but we do an extra show every
single day just for our members it keeps
the show funded it pays for staffs to do
equipment all of that stuff and if we
get 10 new members this evening I will
open up the phone lines okay if people
want to call in at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I
will gladly take phone calls tonight
from leftists rightists whoever ok we
don't we don't screen the phone calls
unless you've already called an a have
you and caller ID in which case we do
screen 10 new members and I will open up
the phone lines don't troll the live
chat we have multiple moderators who are
doing a really great job
we have unbanned Jimmy from Philly who
complained about being banned previously
so he is now allowed to comment again
but you will get banned if you troll and
you can also use the join button down
below in order to get a YouTube channel
membership so let me there's a whole
bunch of comments and questions and
super chats coming in so let me take a
look at those phrenic 32 says why do the
Twitter links to these streams never
work that doesn't sound good
let me take a look at that if that's the
case I've been doing something very very
wrong for a long time David Pakman show
let's take a look here but so here is
the link
we're live streaming now join the
insanity if you click the link and click
play there I am a it's working fine
I don't know what people they're talking
about must be user error of some kind
I'm not sure what to tell you phrenic
okay mark Tenenbaum says on the 510 show
you said business owners should not be
forced to sell ownership to employees do
you support Elizabeth Warren's wealth
tax which will force many to sell
ownership if not enough liquid cash for
tax I address this on today's program
Mark III have serious questions about
the wealth tax idea by Elizabeth Warren
I think that it is legally cleaner to go
after increasing capital gains so here's
the issue when when if we're trying to
so okay if the idea is to use taxation
on the wealthiest in order to fund
programs for the poor and the lower
middle class and in the middle class or
whoever else I think that if you focus
only on income tax rates you're going to
miss a lot of that money because a lot
of rich people are earning most of their
income through business distributions
and through generally what's called
capital gains so you've got to go after
capital gains now some people like
Elizabeth Warren and others are skipping
to a wealth tax and I think that it's a
little bit problematic on two fronts
number one legally I think that it is
difficult to be sure that a wealth tax
would be implementable so to speak and
I've read some legal opinions of to that
of that opinion I also do have a problem
you know if you're taxing the net worth
and not the liquid assets of people a
lot of that net worth could be in stocks
that net worth could be in a business
that one owns or whatever else so you
are absolutely right mark that there are
some real issues with a wealth tax which
could force many to sell ownership if
they don't have enough liquid cash for
tax so I think I don't even know that we
have to go down that road ideologically
yet because I would go after capital
gains right away Demetrios 1975 cent to
$10.00 superjet saying i gave up on dave
rubin about six months ago but if he has
the integrity to sit down with you I'd
be inclined to subscribe to his channel
again also you should interview Tulsi
Gabbard we
invited tulsi gabbard on the show have
not heard back at all from anybody there
so I don't know if she's inclined to be
interviewed by me but I would gladly
welcome her to the program as you're
saying I think that if Dave Rubin sat
down with me for an hour on his show on
my show wherever and we really hash tout
all of these things including some of
his attacks on the left and all of this
other stuff I think that it would do a
lot for his audience I know it would do
a lot for my audience so there's also a
selfish motivation there and I don't
pretend to hide that I think it would
just be good watching and we would
accomplish a lot much more than letting
some right-winger uncontested talk for
an hour and a half
nope games sent a dollar super chat a
cuckold I of kakan sent a $5 super chat
David you really do ask gotcha questions
like what is your political positions
yeah that's a reference I think to the
Rubin interview where there there really
weren't gotcha questions it was quite
quite the opposite but we'll republish
that and I think you will find it
interesting
Alex Malone sent a super chat I was
really excited to call you during the
last livestream and was crushed when I
heard that my number didn't appear can
you check if my number is blocked I
don't have to check Alex because
nobody's numbers are blocked now
sometimes what does happen is people
call in from a different number than
they think they're calling in from so
I'm trying to see if I have on my legal
pad here some of the people who were
getting priority on the last livestream
I don't but like for example sometimes
people will say hey I'm gonna call in
from the six one seven area code and
then they call in from Skype and it
shows a different number in the call
system so nobody's blocked Alex so
that's definitely not the problem but we
will hopefully open the phone lines
today Brian Stevens wants to have a
cooking competition between you and
Ruben between me and Ruben you know I
didn't know Ruben cooked I thought that
Rubens husband did the cooking from what
I've seen on Instagram so I don't know
if the competition should be between
with Ruben or with Rubens husband yeah
aris is
of sends a $2.00 super chat Raygun
mentioned the orange orange gels on the
majority report today you know what's so
funny about that Sam cedar actually
texted me about orange gels but they're
gone as a sort of goof and as a test cuz
I had them lying around because I got a
multi pack of gels I put some orange on
these two panels I guess you would call
them a couple of weeks ago but they
didn't last long I haven't seen that
clip though so if anyone can what's the
easiest way if anyone can super chat a
link to the clip for majority report and
a time code we'll watch it together
because I haven't actually seen that and
I would I would like to see it let me
welcome a new member
Jared Haggerty Jared Haggerty is this
evenings first new member thanks for
signing up on our website Jared let me
mention again I will open up the phone
lines right away okay don't tempt me
because I am ready to open the phone
lines and I will prove it to you at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty as soon as we get to ten new
members membership is the number one
funding source for the show it keeps us
independent it makes us less susceptible
to the devastating effects of YouTube's
the monetization it's just a great thing
to sign up okay and if you sign up on
our website and nine more people do that
today we will open up the phone lines
and I see it's funny just by my mere
mention of the phone number people
immediately start calling in and leaving
voicemails just as like I mean this is
risky but just as a just as a curiosity
let's take a listen to some of the
voicemails that came in even though we
haven't opened the phone lines yet let's
take a listen to one of these how you
doing there baby David Pakman is Johnny
Johnny here and uh out of Arizona and at
the point out the fact that wolf the
bins of Shapiro nonsense that took place
with BBC you gotta destroy this guy man
um I was really I would really enjoy
seeing you debate Ben Shapiro okay well
so it's so funny I mean we opened up
today by talking about
this clamoring for me to debate been or
debate Dave Rubin or whatever I'm glad
to have them on any time I'm glad to
appear with them anytime and we are
going to be republishing my interviews
with both of them next week when I'm on
vacation work trip slash Memorial Day
vacation let's listen to one other
voicemail that came in phone lines not
yet open you could talk to me if we get
nine more new members but for now you
would have to leave a voicemail let's
see
hey Pakman total control eight seven one
yeah so Shapiro had his a total meltdown
and he kind of went out like a one
little [ __ ] but my point is don't well
doesn't everybody do that in their
respective political parties I mean
don't don't you do that true you might
not speak with a whiny little [ __ ]
voice and you might not have had an
on-air or meltdown okay at least not to
date anyway but you pretty much do the
same thing I mean it's a it's a practice
of this is my political view and I am
going to okay him anyway I mean I did
not pre listen to those and as I told
you since yesterday's Ben Shapiro Dave
Rubin segments it has just been crazy I
mean is it's it's constant emails and
tweets and stuff like this coming in
okay let me get back to the Super chats
but again to deal with this ray gun
related thing if somebody can get me a
time code and a link and maybe if
someone can put them in the regular chat
I'll keep an eye out for it as well I
would love to take a look at that and we
can review it together okay uh nope
games sends a dollar super chat thank
you
but boom euro at the buoy add egg Bowie
says after watching today's show I have
to say that my brain is still in
recovery mode from taking in so many
high-level important ideas I don't know
I don't know if that's a Reuben joke or
if there were actually interesting ideas
on on the David Pakman show today but if
you're being serious I do appreciate
that okay
let me see if anybody has sent me the
link yet too
the majority report thing about the sets
today that would be great if someone
posted that but I'm not seeing it maybe
it's taking people a little while to get
it together the link and the time code
but anyway we could we can look at that
together if somehow people get it to me
okay black wave 54 says your was poppin
Pakman do you know what's up with the
embassy ting was really Gucci with that
gangin Gert okay yeah I'm having trouble
understanding that the specifics of your
question but it I do appreciate your
support
Sabrina zafar who's also been fully
deputized as a moderator in the chat how
do we convince people to vote based on
policy during the primaries versus
electability noticing too many
progressive Biden supporters lately yeah
I know exactly what you're talking about
and I think that we I mean I don't know
the answer I genuinely have no idea I
genuinely have no idea and you know
especially when electability matters
here's the thing it's not that we should
ignore electability it's that this is an
election that on turnout to it will
hinge on turnout alone right it was so
close in 2016 in just these few states
that Democrats could easily win that
solely on the basis of turnout there
could be any you know any of the top at
least four if not more Democratic
candidates could actually win in other
words they are electable it's a question
of what the turnout is and that's a part
of electability so I don't have the
answer Sabrina although I wish I did
okay it looks like I've gotten a link
here to the Sam cedar thing I just need
a time code and I don't know let me see
if I can get this pulled up for us so we
can watch it that we will be pre looking
at this together because I haven't seen
this yet yes it's a very long video so
people have to actually give me the time
code for where where it appears because
otherwise I can't look through like a
two-hour stream right now but okay maybe
I have to forget about that because it's
not gonna happen okay let's go back to
the super chat Plato Emerson I'd love to
see you in a suit and tie sometime I
used to wear ties on the show but I did
away with it it just
pointless like I'm my own boss why am i
forcing myself to wear a tie that seems
crazy
Hideyoshi Lacan says I used to
right-wing you used to right-wing but
you helped me change my mind and move
left thank you my pleasure I that is a
good I've done a good deed it's a
mitzvah I appreciate that
Dylan Tyler says hey David I have a
question regarding Ben Shapiro do you
believe that his habit of cherry-picking
facts to push his political agenda hurts
his reputation as a political
commentator yeah so it does hurt his
reputation within people who are
informed enough to recognize that he's
cherry-picking facts but it makes some
very appealing to a larger swath of the
population that is so-called low
information so in the net it's probably
a benefit to him to do that okay let's
see eros is love says that the time code
is 38:46 for the Sam cedar thing now I'm
just I lost the link somehow but how can
I put this shouldn't be so complicated
you know but I am having trouble getting
this together let's take a look here
maybe I can just do Sam cedar and maybe
we can find it let's take a look here
Stream four hours ago okay so we're
gonna go there and then the time code is
38 46 I don't even know what that a 1 11
13 okay so let's skip this ad and go to
1 11 13 and see what happened today 1 11
13 here we go and then it's gonna be
real hard for you to go full hashtag
it's not a Miss donation that'd be
possible but if people want information
that's where it's at alright great and
and these are making that happen that
was really you who who helped promote
that and made that all possible well
good for you for for doing it
alright but let's go return back to more
critical issues and we will put a link
the bond fund page in our podcast and
our YouTube description we do have an
image of David Pakman and a new set what
is this picture well this is from dark
mare and on Twitter mmm so it looks a
little suspicious
we're gonna air it and we'll have our
forensic experts look into it but there
looks like some orange accents yeah it
sure does I mean not looks like it is
orange accents and Alessa now that's not
clear to me that it's actually his set
but if it is it is getting really
problematic really problematic so you
set the tone you already set the tone
and then it's gonna be real hard for you
to go full hashtag spoiler alert
Daenerys season 8 episode 5 well terney
you're gonna get a lot of make it happen
it's my attorney you'll make it happen
all right appreciate the call to start
getting the paperwork ready right one
more call that was it okay yeah so uh
yes I actually texted with Sam about
this today and we were actually texting
about other things but it eventually
came to the orange panels and I am
anticipating a cease-and-desist soon but
I'm actually I'm retaining mark o'meara
I was first gonna be represented by Mark
Geragos celebrity attorney Mark Geragos
but I feel like I need the guy who got
George Zimmerman off on murder charges
because I I need just like the best
whatever the craziest thing that
someone's gotten off of for that's who I
need representing me and that's a
Florida attorney mark o'mara who by the
way I've met and is a really really nice
guy I know a lot of people would say how
nice can you be if you defend George
Zimmerman but he's an extremely nice guy
I once went to a concert with him and a
few other people and it was a weird
weird night very very strange night okay
before I get to more of these super
chats let me welcome a few other new
member
we're looking for 10 new members in
order to open the phone lines this
evening James s rich ash rich I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly is new member
number two of the evening
TJ Tolson is new member number three of
the evening and as an extra incentive
because we're at three out of ten I've
tried this before and people seem to
like it if you are one of the ten new
members who triggers for lack of a
better term the end of a safe space for
me and gets me to open the phone lines
and you want to be one of the first
callers when you sign up for a
membership in either the first or last
name field like if your name was David
Pakman you might put David six one seven
if six one seven was your area code
Pakman when you sign up include your
area code I will make a note on one of
my pads I've got all sorts of pads down
here it's just paperwork after paperwork
I will make a note of your area code so
that when we open the phone lines I will
first go to you okay it's an extra
incentive for the people that get us to
open the phone lines Rand Miller says I
am a recovering addict of about six
years and I would love to see some
talking debates about what to do with
honest help for addiction with
individual care thank you oh that's a
great topic I'm not an expert in it but
an important topic and when I'm glad to
bring experts on to discuss the
progressive voice appears asking could
Vegeta go
Sajid too without Babbitt ease majique
no idea absolutely no idea about any of
that stuff couldn't couldn't couldn't
tell you anything about it Nate with a
thirteen dollar and 99 cent Canadian
thirteen Canadian dollar and 99 cent
Super Shot thoughts on Reubens claim
that TYT has dishonestly presented
Harris and Marv as bigots simply for
criticizing Islam is personally
unsubscribed from TYT for this reason
who reuben unsubscribed from TYT for
that reason i don't necessarily
understand that
i honestly don't have any idea of how t
whitey has presented sam Harris and Bill
Maher I mean I couldn't tell you I saw
like years ago I saw a bunch of that
jancuga sit down with
Harris and other than that I don't know
I mean I barely watch anything Joe
Raider says thoughts on funding NASA to
return to the moon by 2024 will trump
raid education to do it well Trump is
liable to raid anything to do anything
that he determines is politically
advantageous I've been advocating for
going back to the moon for a couple of
years now and I think that given
everything that we now know and the
advancement of space travel technology
since we last went to the moon there
would be huge benefits and and the moon
would be a really important testing
ground for further space travel so I
absolutely would be up for funding NASA
for a return to the moon and 2024 sounds
great sooner sounds great also right I
mean whenever we can do it no question
and yes Trump may well raid education in
order to do it
Demetrios 1975 says I know you spent
money on new hey treat male background
music but I think you should ditch it
and go back to the original music the
new music is clunky and doesn't flow
well with the narration I don't know
about that let's see if we can let's
take a look at some hey treat male we
have three or actually I don't even need
to do that I have a better way of doing
this I can just pull up the three songs
that we use for hey treat male and then
we can take sort of like an insta Pole
okay so the original hey treat male
music was I guess it's this one let's
take a listen to this one oh sorry no
you know what I'm so deep this is the
that's the actual intro music man I'm
not gonna be able to easily do it I
think is there you know what I think
it's gonna be overly complex for me to
do that right now you know people are
mixed and there's always the
self-selection where people who dislike
stuff we do are much more likely to
reach out than people who like something
so we're gonna stick with the three
different backing tracks for hatred mail
for now and then we will make it a
further decision later on in the year
heiresses love thank you for sending me
the time code for the Sam cedar thing we
looked at it Sox fan two to three says
Dave my conservative girlfriend
it's catching me watching David Pakman
clips online advice on getting her on
board
ideologically I don't want to play
conservative yeah whoa
I would be extraordinarily careful
extraordinarily careful about how you
manage this situation Sox fan I you know
there are lots you don't reason your way
into being a right winger so the idea of
just reasoning someone out of it is
difficult and you've also got a very
touchy situation because you know this
is your girlfriend so I don't know I
think I would just continue playing
clips in the background and see if it
will sort of by by by sheer you know
repetition maybe invade her safe space
Jimmy from Philly has sent a super chat
jelly sandwiches stigmatized kids at
school bahaha I hope that was worth two
bucks Jimmy but you know what I really
can't criticize Jimmy from Philly Jimmy
from Philly is a violent in his rhetoric
trumpet
he is a david pakman show member okay
for all of the progressives who can
afford three bucks a month and who like
the show and aren't supporting us
financially Jimmy from Philly who leaves
voicemail messages like this one I
haven't listened to this so this could
be crazy let's see
David Jimmy from Philly you worked at
Circuit City I made up a protest sign in
front of Circuit City and that's a in
diction City Pennsylvania I bought a CD
scratch fixer thingy for like twenty
some dollars and it didn't work and I
brought it back and the guys there
together Lisa absolutely riveting but in
any case that guy is a member he just
sent a two dollar super chat okay so
anyway the point is we can't just be
funded by conservatives we've got to
also be funded by progressives and
that's why I want to say thanks to Brian
Parker Brian Parker from the seven six
zero area code is new number
new member number four of the evening so
I'm gonna make a note right down here
seven six zero
is Brian Parker and if we open up the
phone lines if we get six more new
members we will go first to Brian who
has certainly earned the right to be
heard from first for sure okay Dylan
Tyler says as a follow-up to my previous
question would you consider giving your
viewers all the relevant facts and
allowing them to come to their own
conclusion paramount to being a
respectable commentator if you mean am I
willing to make this no longer an
opinion show the answer is no I think
that would be horribly boring horribly I
mean listen that's what I tried to do in
like the first six months of the show
just on the one hand and on the other
hand and I don't take a position and the
show was going nowhere so no I don't
want to commit programming suicide so
this will it has to remain an opinion
show Dylan that that's that's a key part
of what the program is Sam Dean says
g'day mate here's a donation to help buy
your lawyer a coffee JAL gate will not
bring us down comrade no retreat no
surrender cheers from Oz thank you very
much cuckold eye of cacao says David
just declare yourself as a sovereign
citizen and problem solved I don't know
if you mean with regard to paying taxes
or or what Jessica Everett is a new
YouTube member Jessica used the join
button down below and she is new member
number five of the evening were halfway
to ten and when we get to ten I will
open up the phone lines people are just
very very excited about the possibility
of the phone lines opening I see one two
three more voicemails that have come in
even though the phone lines aren't yet
open the phone lines have not yet opened
but if they do I will be fair to tell
you indie odd-jobs
says do you believe the two-party system
should be excised well the two-party
duopoly must be gotten rid of but
unfortunately it's going to take a bunch
of different systemic changes to make
that a reality one we probably need to
get rid of the electoral college in
order to have serious third-party
representation in our
a congressional and political system in
number two we've got to redo from the
ground up the campaign finance and pulp
finance of politics infrastructure so
that we can better allow third parties
to be represented and not to feel and
actually be potential spoilers which is
why a lot of people don't support third
parties so yeah I want to get away from
the two-party duopoly but we need some
big systemic change to make it happen
ghost of a dead meme says David you need
to get twitch there's no downside you
know I've been thinking about starting
to produce content for twitch and the
easiest way to start would be to Simon
YouTube and twitch stuff at the same
time but unfortunately twitch doesn't
allow that if you want to monetize I
believe someone wrote to me and said
that's not a good idea
and I just don't know that I have the
bandwidth right now to be independently
producing just like a ton of extra
twitch stuff because I'm I'm pretty busy
believe it or not
chuckle die of cacao says David are you
pro-nuclear as a stepping stone yes I'm
not gonna delve into that in too much
detail because I have numerous clips
about that but yes I am reck soul says
do you like it cloud strife or Sephiroth
I don't know if those are video games or
heavy metal bands unfortunately I'm very
very out of the loop phrenic 32 says
Jimmy from Philly is a Pakman plant I
assure you that he is not I assure you
that he is absolutely not a plant he is
he is what he is and in his full glory
ey TPS says David Pakman will you ever
interviewed an Penna I have no idea who
that is
let's look that up Dan Penna dan panna
also known as Dan pena is an American
businessman he resides at Guthrie Castle
in Scotland oh I actually have heard of
this guy and I would be very interested
in interviewing him yeah I would love to
have him on if he's willing and I don't
know if he is Gabriel fret sends a 50
Norwegian kroner super chat watching Ben
Shapiro disaster while being very
familiar with
Andrew Neil made it ten times funnier
yeah I'm only tangentially familiar with
Andrew Neil so I actually had to
research him to understand like the full
scope of what was going on there but it
was uh it was an implosion to the enth
degree for sure let me welcome a couple
of other people
Christopher Howard is a new patron
patron I will count patrons okay in fact
I will give you an extra possibility for
getting us to open the phone lines this
evening let me pull up my patreon page
david pakman show let me see here we've
not done a lot i have really let the
patreon page trail off and we were once
at 2,000 patrons and we're down to only
1422 so let me let me say the following
if we get ten even one dollar one dollar
patreon contributions whichever we get
to first ten members or ten patreon
contributions and patreon contributions
start at just $1 when you hit this
orange become a patron button I will
open the phone lines okay and that means
that with only ten more dollars can
truly eight ten one dollar contributions
we might have those phone lines open
before you know it so Christopher Howard
is patron number one of the evening then
we have a new member number six of the
evening Trevor Christiansen and new
member number seven of the evening
Stephen Davis and new member number
eight of the evening Abhaya dake or doc
a I'm not sure how to pronounce the last
name so we are at eight new members and
we are at one new patron when we get to
ten of either of them I will open the
phone lines up and I see that Karem from
Boston is calling in feverishly I see
that Hassan from Dallas is calling in
and everybody just wants to get on today
and there will be that opportunity
believe me if we get ten new patrons or
ten new members and it will be
extraordinarily exciting that I assure
you a dev is a new YouTube member thank
you for signing up
Joe Raider says everyone tune into
SpaceX is unprecedented launch of their
own 60 satellites at once
tomorrow at once maybe maybe that me
at 1:00 tomorrow on YouTube if not
delayed I will be paying attention to
that if it works with the show schedule
for sure
Murphy Rogan seems to have ties with
higher-ups at Twitter and YouTube could
we see a YouTube presidential debate
maybe for those who don't make it on the
main stage that would be fascinating and
I will volunteer myself to moderate if
Rogan would have me yeah yo soy baboso
says a mlo wants to decriminalize all
drugs and negotiate with the United
States to do the same yeah I'm all for
decriminalization of drugs I've said I
am still undecided about legalization of
like cocaine and heroin I've seen good
arguments for and against then I've just
not yet taken a position on that
Randy H says I started a membership
about a week or two ago and it's great
for twitch I would just do the double
stream not make content use it as a
gateway to YouTube
yeah the thing is if I do twitch I think
if I'm just using it as a gateway to
YouTube I don't know how worthwhile it
will be because I have no audience on
Twitch so I'd have to build an audience
from scratch in order to get them to
YouTube so i think monetizing twitch is
the logical thing but i've been told if
you are Simon the same stuff to twitch
that you do to YouTube that there is no
monetization available or they don't
they don't want you monetizing it I
don't know the pyro tyrant's is a new
YouTube member very much appreciate that
and oh we've got a bunch of different I
think the phone lines are probably
getting open soon so phrenic 31 is new
patron number two of the evening Patrick
Burns is new patron number three of the
evening and part REO is new patron
number four of the evening so that gets
us to four new patrons Matthew bar is
new patron number five of the evening
it's gonna be it's gonna be a race I
said that if we get 10 new members or 10
new patrons I'll open up the phone lines
were at 8 new members and 5 new patrons
let me refresh this but patrons are
coming fast and furious at this point
so I wonder where I wonder what will
lead to the phone lines being open first
and the phone lines are blowing up Jimmy
from Phillies trying to get on again
Hasan from Dallas is still trying to get
on fever and Lee I wonder if fever is
still an urban dictionary let me look at
that
urban dictionary fever --nt yeah here it
is this is so funny
fever and top definition adjective
wildly zealous a portmanteau of feverish
and fervent unintentionally coined by
Louis Motamedi of the David Pakman show
it seems like the oh no this is a direct
quote it seems like the only people who
are going to vote for Rand Paul are that
small libertarian section of the
Republican Party and they're very
passionate and fever --nt and they
support him with every fiber of their
being I love that so Louie yeah that's
an old thing from former producer Louis
well this that just got a little crazy
and I saw producer Louis today he parked
his car at my place because he he's
actually on route to Japan today just
for kicks you know what let's do
something fun which we never do on the
show let's track Louis's flight to Japan
he is on let's see the Japanese Airlines
flight from Boston to Tokyo let's see
we're like I'm gonna tell you exactly
we're producer lewis's right now in case
you're curious it is this flight right
here JAL 7 and he is over very northern
Alaska can you imagine right now being
Louis over very northern Alaska and
having no idea I guess that we're
talking about him right now but that's
where Lewis's and he has left his car
under my supervision for the duration of
his trip and I'm gonna be beating the
hell out of that thing so he is going to
come back to something very very very
very disappointing for sure
okay let me get to a couple of other
super chats here let's see
smells like purple says I once called to
ask a question and thought my number was
up when I heard you say just the first
two 7s after that I heard for my dreams
were crushed nothing to say now just
wanted to support you rest in peace of
7:5 yeah I go to 774 often because it's
a local area code
but I will go to 775 as well Joe Rader
says the SpaceX launch is at 9:30 p.m.
Central Time a dev says how do you stay
so calm in this completely insane
environment it's the sensitization I
wish I had a better explanation but it's
just being desensitized to the insanity
of American politics
Demetrios sit 1975 you should go on Joe
Rogan's podcast kolinsky and door have
been on twice I think you'd be great
also Rogan likes you I would love to be
on with Joe Rogan and hopefully I will
soon be able to announce that I'm going
to be on Ash daddy says what
organizations would you recommend for
progressives AC 210 I don't know what
that means for progressives ac 200 area
code 210 I don't know I hesitate to
recommend organizations to people for a
bunch of different reasons including
that I don't know if that many
organizations I apologize okay we're
gonna get the phone lines open because
we are just receiving a flood of new
members let's see David Gwyn win-win-win
I always am unsure how to say it is a
new member thank you zey Nassif or
Nassif is a new member and Jake from the
three one three area code is a new
member so I am right now opening up the
phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I'm
gonna make a note that Jake from 3 1 3
wants to get on and then we will go to
the phone lines 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 by all
means continue with the Super chats and
the because I will I will get to those
and new memberships and patreon and all
of that different stuff but I will check
in with some people on the phone I
promised that I would do it and it would
be very dishonest if I didn't let's see
I'm gonna go to Hasan from Dallas in a
second just give me a second Hasan it
just takes a moment for the system to be
fully engaged I need to activate the
system on my end
[Music]
okay see here okay Hassan from Dallas
you should be on what's going on today
hello hey Hassan what's going on oh is
this Sean I'm sorry it's Sean
it's the Sean baby Sean jeez Sean okay I
had you in the system as I son you
probably were wondering who I was
talking about okay Deshawn formerly his
son I will update that in our system
thank you okay oh really yeah so I came
here my first question is do you support
the expansion of the House of
Representatives in the house
representatives by a couple hundred
seats I've been actually reading a
couple articles saying that our house
representatives here in the United
States is currently captain somewhere
like in the 400s but if we were to
actually have a house representative
that was more aligned with like a lot of
other industrialized countries that have
like algorithmic you know they add seats
based on some kind of like algorithmic
thing that they have that we don't have
in our Constitution and so if we were to
do that our current house
representatives the amount of
Representatives that they have for a
nation of 350 million people is
somewhere around like a 900 feet yeah I
am in favor of that and so here's the
thing I think that we need to have each
member of Congress representing fewer
people I think right now it's about
750,000 people roughly in each
congressional district I think that's
too much and I do want to I would like I
would be in support of that okay awesome
and then I brought that up because you
talked about the electoral college
earlier you know you're talking about
that so I wanted to support it that
those cool um and my second part that I
cross are like my second question which
is kind of irrelevant to the first I was
not Andrew yang and I know I don't know
I saw posted on Twitter commented to
Carlos what's his name but he basically
had had retweeted Pete Budaj as press
secretary who was talking about I saw
that yes asked
they've ruined two DMM on Twitter to set
up something but I thought Andrew yang
apparently has already you know decided
he was going to go into de Bourbon show
but it what's interesting for me with
that I don't know about you it's just
like I get like listen I get you want to
show up to like right-winger like shows
you know for Andrew yang but isn't it
kind of bizarre that he seems to be so
fervent at doing it and he doesn't
really like how do I put it he's he's
not a great debater on the issues like
he doesn't debate again he provides a
platform he's not really debating he's
not debating anyone right and so he goes
on but he went on ben shapiro show and
that the sunday sit down that i thought
was kind of bad because he ended up
backtracking at least in my opinion of
why i thought he wasn't the green new
deal he kind of actually took a
republican talking point and was he
literally said on there that glow that
even at the united states even if the
United States did like you know go 100
percent renewable that it wouldn't
matter because we're only 13% of the
global emissions it's just like well we
have to be a leader yeah III would have
liked to have actually just seen that
been more adversarial and have them
actually hash out ideas rather than yeah
that's Ben Shapiro like if there's
someone you're gonna have a debate with
or you should have policy conflicts with
you think it'd be Ben Shapiro if you're
on the Left
you know what yeah that's really
disappointing sigh Andrew yang has been
really a missing like missing a lot for
me well I have every time I have a man I
questioned him about all of this stuff
people have a problem with and I'll
certainly do it again DeSean thank you
for the call I appreciate it thank you
all right take care
let's see so I've got my priority caller
let's see do we have someone from seven
six oh yes we do let me go right to the
seven six oh because seven six oh I
believe is Brian Parker is that you
Brian yeah hey how's it going for your
support Brian yeah no problem
wow I'm really surprised them on the
show hey David I'm a big fan
I'm 21 years old I live in New York my
zip code is or my area code is from
California but anyway I moved to New
York cause of the army I was stationed
at Fort Drum and I was a young person I
was actually a early Donald Trump
supporter hmm and my time in the
military and just getting a little older
kinda woke me up and I kind of I
completely turned around I'm now like a
progressive and I think what have a lot
to do with that was right-wing
propaganda in the media hmm well in
social media I just wanted to ask what
you thought about that so you're saying
the right-wing propaganda is what
initially indoctrinated you into
trumpism or you ended up leaving
trumpism because of right-wing
propaganda that you saw and didn't like
oh no no as a young person I was
influenced by the right wing like
isoquants on social media which and I
saw the right wing is kind of like fax
over feelings type of thing and I was
like a really big supporter and but some
experience I had experiences I had in
the military really changed my mind and
yeah but listen you know what I want to
Norma Rocco chamber of right-wing
propaganda is is absolutely devastating
and toxic and right you're an example of
how you got into that now what's like
one experience in the military that
changed your mind I went through a lot
of abuse in the military from people who
were very ardent Trump supporters you
know right-wing kind of fairy I saw a
lot of racism a lot of homophobia in the
military and it really woke me up I
realized that the hateful people in the
military it just really changed my mind
you know what's an end about that Brian
is that there are others who
means the same thing in the military and
they become more right-wing so you know
I interesting to think about why for you
it had the repellent effect yes that
interests me too because I know a lot of
people in the military that are just
kind of going with the flow because it
really is an environment of abuse and a
lot of times the military is a great
institution but the right-wing majority
in the military really indoctrinates
people and they just kind of have to
stay in that ideology and yeah it had a
profound impact on me very interesting
very very interesting Brian I appreciate
your support thanks for being a member
and really appreciate you sharing your
experience thank you for having me on
my pleasure absolutely okay I'm next
going to go to three one three because
that's another new member but let me go
through a couple super chats here
picturing my love says I recently bought
the Holy Bible and the Quran to see for
myself what they have to offer what book
should I start reading first on Google
Play Books I have no idea I mean there's
hundreds of books I could recommend to
you depending on what what you're
looking for but check my book
recommendation segments and I have a
whole page on the david pakman show
website that has a long list of books
that i've recommended over the over the
years craw Rennie says have you heard of
Nikko house of M CSC he accuses you of
being a centrist neoliberal often do you
think that's a fair description of your
politics an example can be seen at the
2856 mark of a video he did with Kyle I
presume kolinsky I've heard the name
because it's one of the people that
would sometimes appear that people would
be tweeting me stuff in those barage
--is of you know here here's like the
the firm the the the guy Jimmy from
Philly talks about like the firm bastard
or something like that here's this other
person I have not seen what you're
talking about and I'm not a centrist
neoliberal I just did my political
compass thing and I'm more left than
I've ever been almost off the charts so
and I
I don't really watch any of that stuff
I'm just yet check out my interview
today with Cal Newport about reducing
noise an increasing signal and you'll
very quickly understand why I pay
effectively no attention to the cottage
industry of people who just make videos
criticizing me I'm just busy hosting my
show
cuckold I of caki David have you
considered doing what some consider Pro
men's rights activist videos I know for
sure that will open the door for many
right-wingers on YouTube I know when
Anna Cade did this it worked Pro men's
rights activist videos no that's not
something I've considered doing and
cuckold I of kakan says can you ask
progressive voice to unblock hassan and
release him from the gulag of twitter of
tweeter i don't know anything about that
okay let's go to the three one three
area code who i believe is is this Jake
Osborne new member Jay cause born yeah
this is hey Jake how you do wanna go for
your support yeah no problem thanks for
your show I've been watching the show
for I think two years now going on two
years and my girlfriend and I really
enjoy your content no good thank you
um so I'm calling from Grand Rapids and
I'm sort of like the last caller my
question has to do with um the sort of
anti sjw movement you find on YouTube I
guess I just wanted to get your thoughts
on what do you think is creating this
appetite for that kind of content
in your opinion what do you think is
doing it because if I can go ahead no no
god I was gonna add like I got sucked
into that whole movement because I
really um it's interesting I actually
like Let's Plays and watching fatigue
like video game culture on YouTube as a
huge following yeah and I am I really
got like into game grumps and there was
a guy on that channel called John and
now he has his own channel called
jontron and then he sort of got you know
there was a big scandal with John you
may have heard about where he actually
went on I don't even know who jontron is
honestly that well it all it's all tied
together because um Destiny's actually
interviewed him and that created a huge
scandal and I didn't like that because I
kind of liked John
and so it kind of like threw me down
this rabbit hole of all this like
because it basically sucked me into the
rabbit hole the anti estate W movement
and then it you know how the algorithm
is super dangerous I just I got sucked
into that and then long story short you
pulled me out of it thank you here's
what I think okay here's my bit I mean
we could there's no one explanation for
why ant is JW content is appealing to
everybody because it's different for
different people but here's a couple
different things to understand number
one anytime that you see something so
the term sjw has become stigmatized and
sort of weaponized as something that you
use against people there is no serious
case to be made that there are not
structural realities that prevent
everyone from experiencing society and
culture in the same way and if you want
social justice part of it is recognizing
that these structural inequalities exist
and working to reduce them now are there
examples of people who go overboard of
course there are but the anti SJW
movement has sort of weaponized that
anti sentiment by caricaturing it and
the most important element to me of why
these movements are appealing it's
similar actually with the race and IQ of
the race realists it's that we often as
people just have these instincts towards
simple explanations for stuff and when
you find material that seems to credibly
reinforce that the simple explanation
and the easy explanation is the right
one it's really appealing to people so
like as an example the race realists
right you have all sorts of people who
have built up this idea that people who
are not successful and people who are
poor and people who commit more crime or
whatever are doing those things because
they are either inherently less
intelligent or bad people or whatever
and then in order to like break that
apart you really need to do some serious
work right you need to
really understand history and sociology
and economics and all of this different
stuff so when someone shows up and says
hey you know what you don't have to do
that difficult stuff the thing that you
sort of instinctively went towards which
some might call racist xenophobic
whatever discriminatory it was right and
it's okay that you're thinking that
that's super appealing and that's the
same thing with with the anti-us JW
movement so-called calls for social
justice make us have to deal seriously
and deeply with ugly realities about
society and culture
if someone swoops in and says these
sjw's are just bonkers and we've got to
ignore them and move ahead because
they're making bad arguments and that's
it that is really easy and appealing and
safe for a lot of people and that's what
I think a lot of the appeal is to give
you it may be a longer answer than you
were looking for no I completely agree
with that that's more along the lines of
what I saw and I'm speaking as somebody
who did kind of get sucked into that for
a little bit I noticed there was a huge
appetite just to see like young
passionate people getting owned I mean
that that's who these guys are debating
most of the time yeah steven crowder ben
shapiro they get money from debating
eighteen-year-olds yep it's pretty
embarrassing and that's another reason
why I thought that videos him just
getting completely destroyed by um by a
guy who do you know and debate them and
just asks questions yeah I mean it's
crazy I mean that that's I mean talk
about throwing all your cards on the
table there I'm yeah I'm can see right
through is a operation now well hey
thanks so much for taking my call Jake
my pleasure really appreciate your
support and appreciate that you signed
up for membership today yeah my pleasure
all right let me thank a couple of other
people I want to say thanks to Nina trim
Beth who is a new david pakman show
member really appreciate that let's go
to the four one three area code anytime
I see a caller from four one three my
home area code I go right to it
who's calling today from the four one
three uh hey this is Georgia I'm from
Springfield hey Jordan what's going on
hey so um I had a kind of an identity
politics question draw
you're obviously aware of the old
what's-his-name Sam Harris meme of
Islamophobia in regards to the left of
the left conflating criticism with Islam
with criticism of Muslims people as you
know you felt with reza aslan for
instance my question is do you think
there's a similar meme of anti-semitism
on the right where they conflate
criticism of Israel with anti-semitism
outright yeah the more things I here's
the thing
there is understand that there is no
answer I could give you that is not
going to as always just cause a
shitstorm of people saying I'm either
wrong on one side or another side but
here's the reality the reality is
nuanced okay criticism of Israeli
foreign policy is not inherently
anti-semitic criticism of Israeli
domestic policy is not inherently
anti-semitic criticism of the Benjamin
Netanyahu administration for what it is
as a right-wing administration is not
inherently anti-semitic so criticism of
all of those things is not definitive
evidence of anti-semitism at the same
time there are people who shield their
anti-semitism as a policy critique or
whatever else so you there is no set
rule right you you have to understand
just because you see criticism of Israel
doesn't mean that it's anti-semitic at
the same time just because someone
claims that a critique is a shield for
anti-semitism doesn't mean that they are
wrong all of these things exist all
right saulius right okay oh I appreciate
it Jordan thank you appreciate it great
to hear from you okay let me look at a
couple of other super chats that are
coming in the New York Times has
apologized for a cartoon published
portraying Trump as a blind man being
guided by the Israeli prime minister do
you consider it anti-semitic regards
from Portugal I considered it sort of
stupid but I did not consider it
inherently anti-semitic I think that the
imagery did was very similar to
anti-semitic imagery but you know the
New York Times recognizes that it was a
bad idea to publish that and and they
apologized and I think that that that's
that bolon Newland
from Sweden I believe Tim Poole
announced he is taking a break maybe you
explaining that Twitter don't
consciously target right-wingers but
rather target ideas made him quit I had
no idea and you know I was actually a
little worried because after the the one
hour thing we did last week I sent him
an email and said you know
thanks I think it went well I just
straight up never heard back from him
and I didn't know what was going on and
I didn't uh had no idea he was taking a
break I will look into that Jimmy from
Philly says that's the hard bastard you
you're afraid to debate okay Jimmy thank
you and Aris is love says that the
majority report ever noticed the David
Pakman show with David Pakman logo you
put up a while back I laughed out loud
at that love the set drama yeah I posted
that to Instagram recently by the way if
you're not following me on instagram
follow me on instagram there is
hilarious stuff I'm at David Pakman
follow me follow me follow me um I
posted a few funny photo shops of the
Sam set thing and I think that Sam did
notice it although we didn't talk to too
much about it
okay let's go back to the phones let's
go to what looks interesting here you
know what I said I'd go to 775 the next
time I saw it and I'm gonna go to 775
although I don't know if this is that
person from 775 who's this hey David am
I on yes you are who's this this is
Roberts the same person from before hey
how's it going Robert I'm all right
there was kind of surreal I'm not gonna
lie good very good I'm good start
so I there's a question I had last time
I remembered after leaving the super
chat okay so I am a more left-wing
person and I live in a very conservative
area sure and one thing I plan on doing
at some point is moving out but then I
said but when I think about that just so
that I have someone that's actually
representing me in office and also not
crazy about the area in general but
that's a big factor in it but my
question is do you think that this sort
of leaving the conservative area
as a left-wing person sort of gives or
takes away power from the left when
there's not the representation or any
left-wing people in those conservative
areas yeah I mean you know in a lot of
ways it does so listen I live in Boston
Massachusetts it's it's despite serious
problems that we have in Boston with
racism and segregation and stuff it is a
very progressive place I think it's
great to live in Massachusetts and I
would have a really hard time moving to
a conservative area but I recognize that
my vote and my activism is probably more
effective in a mathematical sense in
those red areas than in blue states so I
do think that if you you know add your
name to the Hat in a place that's
already represented mostly by Democrats
there's a very small chance you're gonna
have nearly the impact that you might be
able to have by trying to turn you know
a district blue that's already red for
sure but you got to do what's good for
you as well you know yeah right that's
pretty much all I had to say thanks for
answering that day all right thank you
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to our caller from the 6:36 area code
who's calling from 6:36 today hi David
yes I first time caller I just signed up
my name is Maya oh great thank you so
much for calling yeah so um as you can
tell I have an accent I'm not new to you
as I've been here for over a decade have
I just became an American citizen so now
I'm kind of following the political
scene trying to see where I belong great
and my initial I used to live in
Missouri and so that's when I moved to
the US so I had a lot of Republicans who
a you know who kept being painted a
picture about like the United States and
at that point in time I thought I was a
Republican however now I kind of have my
own thoughts my own in terms of like the
known research to understand I'm making
history understand why things are in you
know things I said in ways which I feel
like even Americans themselves don't
kind of place a lot of emphasis on
because a lot of things
very these already what is heard in the
media what people go off on so for
example a lot of people do follow what
like the I heard there's always this
kind of I'm black however there's always
this idea that black people are this way
cuz they are lazy however nobody ever
goes to look into the history of what
late setting precedent for things to be
in a particular way anyway and that is
just a background about me my main
question I had is am as I now I would
align more to Democrats what I've come
to realize is Democrats are really good
at losing which it reads me all the time
their quest to have the best ideas I
have I'm highly educated because I have
and my graduate education I'm going to
pursue my PhD however and we ever look
into economics and everything Democrats
have the best ideas if you search up in
American history
usually on a Democratic president that's
when things actually get better however
how come always Democrats are the worst
marketers in actually letting the
American public know that he actually
had a one who usually move the needle in
the right direction
yeah this is a common issue and I've
talked about it a lot so part of it is
like messaging and framing and George
Lakoff has written a lot of interesting
stuff about that and I really his books
are pretty quick reads and and very
informative so I recommend you check
that out there is a sort of structural
advantage that the right has because a
lot of their positions are just far
simpler they don't need much explanation
so you know if you are just against
taxes the taxes aren't ever going to be
zero so you just say hey we just need to
lower taxes lower lower lower the lower
the taxes the better taxes are theft you
go as crazy as you want
the left's position isn't the opposite
of that it's not higher taxes higher
higher higher
it's we need a reasonable level of
Taxation that will fund what we want
etc abortion the right says abortions
murder were against it the left is not
about we love abortion more abortions
it's a sort of nuanced and detail
requiring perspec
and that's just a structural advantage
for the right so I think that those two
plus many other reasons are a part of
why Democrats are at significant
disadvantages okay but even I get that
and I do understand I think actually
that is 100 percent I'm right however I
think it becomes of politics I think
Democrats are just really really
terrible I is something that I just come
in to terms with it it annoys me so much
because even when you follow like and
like every time Republicans I was able
to sit a narrative and then Democrats
are now chasing after what the
Republican said so every time it seems
the Republicans are the ones who are
sitting there and the table the
Democrats are now the ones who are
actually now having to defend while the
sunset haven't even done anything and
sometimes I'm like really why can't you
guys learn to market yourself which I'd
been I just don't understand and the
next thing that I just wanted to touch
on was am I do go through a lot of your
concert on on YouTube and I'm always
wondering why he don't talk a little bit
more about state issues for example and
when did them Democrats won the house
and a lot of Republican legislators
pushed certain bills to limit their and
the the governorship of certain
Democrats are worn in with cars and all
of that and I yeah
we we did talk about me we've talked
about it to some degree you know I
always want to balance if I go to niche
then the majority of the audience it's
not relevant to the majority of the
audience so that's just kind of like a
balancing that that we we have to do
abaya I really appreciate the call in
your support I've got a bunch of people
holding so I'm going to move on but I
hope to hear from you again for sure a
couple of super chats that have come in
Sam says what's the deal with those evil
new abortion and miscarriage laws is
that a real thing or just smoke being
blown sorry for being vague Cheers made
yes so here's that the idea is now that
trumps put two more Supreme Court has
two Supreme Court justices that he
selected they see blood in the water
when it comes to a
abortion so the idea of a lot of these
laws is gets get a court case get a
lawsuit over one of the laws appeal to
the Supreme Court which they see is
possibly opening up the door to a
anti-abortion anti abortion decision
that will let them restrict abortions
further at the state level that that's
the endgame eros is love asks Eric Trump
big gums or tiny teeth yeah that's
interesting it sometimes when you see
that it's a condition called bruxism but
I actually have not really noticed that
with Eric Trump I think I I wouldn't be
able to say which it is a Twinkie boy
says amaze in thank you bowling Newlands
says I think YouTube click holes and
pipelines are only a problem if the
person is lazy minded or a malleable
child if you know why you are left-wing
you can watch right-wing content without
conforming absolutely and I actually
will very often say not interested in
this and a little thing comes up that
says why and I will very often put I
don't want to see anything from this
channel or I just don't like the video
and that has also helped me to get a
YouTube algorithm feed that I like much
more and I don't even really watch like
political stuff it's mostly you know
just the chess stuff and and other
things I'm interested in eat music one
says why did you considered the cartoon
stupid did the New York Times apologized
because it also thought it was stupid I
don't think so I don't know why the New
York Times I believe apologized because
they thought that it wasn't appropriate
not because they thought it was stupid
and I thought it was stupid because I
thought it was overly simplistic and
also not the primary area of concern in
terms of foreign influence leading
Donald Trump so to speak so I thought
that it sort of lost the plot white
death asks have you heard about China's
internment camps for youger Muslims and
will you do a segment on it have heard
about it don't know enough about it will
certainly research and do a segment
about it let's go to the 9:02 area code
who's calling today from the 9:02 area
code
hi this me that is you yeah who's this
oh hi this is Trevor calling from Nova
Scotia hey Trevor yeah I just had a
quick comment and a political question I
mean a couple of weeks ago I actually
suggested to you in the chat that you do
a collaboration with philosophy tube and
some of the other people on the chat
suggested I check out the Contra points
channel which at the time I'd never
really heard of so I thought okay well
maybe I'll check it out and I think
about a week later that was when you had
Natalie on and so I decided to check
with the channel and basically I became
obsessed with it I watched every single
video on the channel and some of them
more than one so I just want to thank
you in the audience thanks cover and you
doesn't just put us on speakerphone did
you know I think my face might have
gotten a little bit far from the screen
okay all right yeah yes the Contra
points is fantastic yeah I love it I
want to ask you about campaign funding
okay when a couple of occasions you
expressed concern over the policy that
some progressive candidates are adopting
in which they're basically refusing
donations from political action
communities large corporations lobbyists
and so on so the way that you seem to
frame the issue is that refusing these
funding sources is good from an ethics
or accountability standpoint but that
hurts the candidates electoral chances
in the in the general election in the
general election I made I clarified so
some of the other progressive
commentators seem to present it as so
not only a good thing ethically but also
good in terms of strategy since it
untethered them from sort of feeling
pressure from the donors allowing them
to offer more audacious sort of less
interest policies and also because it
allows them to call out their opponents
corruption which seems to be really
valuable as a major issue for many
voters well that does seem to hurt Trump
too much right I mean when Trump Trump
would always just say hey I'm just
playing the game really well that that's
it and and so i don't know that i think
i mean i think that that's a perfectly
reasonable position to take I just don't
know that it's borne out by the facts
that it actually has that net benefit
that you're describing or that others
that you're citing are describing
well in fairness of course Hillary
didn't really have the ability to call
him oppa because she wasn't and of
refusing any of those donations or so so
I'm not sure that would be I mean yes no
I I do think that she did criticize him
I guess I I'm my memory is not super
precise around exactly that that issue
I'd have to go back and look at some of
the debates I guess to be able to
comment more precisely my pleasure thank
you for the call really really much very
much appreciate it I gotta go I will try
to do another stream this week because
I'm going away for a while I'm gonna be
gone for a while there's gonna be no
streams for who knows how long so I will
try to do at least one more stream this
week thanks to everybody who called in
thanks to everybody who signed up
patreon YouTube super chats all of that
stuff